all right so next part of this
incredible story part one is trump under
criminal investigation part two a number
of statements from the attorney general
merrick garland over the last week or
ten days indicating a willingness
at least theoretically to prosecute a
former president okay we have been
waiting for these signals the first
signal is the following here is an
interview with lester holt that merrick
garland did yesterday you said in no
uncertain terms the other day that no
one is above the law
that said um
the indictment of a former president of
perhaps candidate for president
would arguably tear the country apart is
that your concern as you make your
decision down the road here i really
hope that's not his concern
do you have to think about things like
that look we pursue
justice without fear or favor
we intend to hold everyone anyone who is
criminally responsible
for events surrounding january 6
for any attempt to interfere with the
lawful transfer of power from one
administration to another accountable
that's what we do
we don't pay any attention to
other
issues with respect to that so donald
trump were to become a candidate for
president again that would not change
your schedule or how you move forward or
don't move forward
say again that uh we will hold
accountable anyone who was criminally
responsible for attempting to interfere
with the transfer legitimate lawful
transfer of power from one
administration to the next so that is
quite clear from merit garland that is
quite clear and there has been an
increased increasingly noticeable shift
in this direction now on july 20th this
was about a week ago merrick garland
also made very clear and that's the
statement that was referenced no person
is above the law also believed to be a
signal about what may be coming we are
entering a zone here where
if there are charges brought against a
former president related to january 6
doj could be accused of playing politics
how
is the department how are you weighing
that also do you think that there is a
constitutional question volunteer about
whether you charge a former president or
actions allegedly taken during his term
separately
jalen walker okay
i'll answer that okay well let me answer
the first one okay okay look
no person
is above the law in this country
nothing stops us
no i don't know how to say that again
no person is above the law in this
country i can't say it any more clearly
than that
there is nothing in the principles of
prosecution in any other factors which
prevent us from investigating anyone
anyone who's criminally responsible
uh for for uh
an attempt to undo a democratic election
so that was the first signal that
there was something going on and then of
course over the last 24 hours we have
learned trump under criminal
investigation by the federal
government the justice department a
major major deal which we will continue
to follow now again
i don't want i don't want to be negative
i don't want to be pessimistic
but
do i really see charges announced
against donald trump by merrick garland
i don't know that i do i don't know that
i do but i will of course concede
i think it is more likely today than at
any point over the last two three years
during which i've been asked about it
again and again and again let me know
where you are you can find me on twitter
at dpakman what do you expect at this
point and do the last 24 hours change
your opinion the only subscription
streaming service dedicated to
documentaries is curiosity stream one of
our sponsors if you love documentaries
like me
you should really check out
curiositystream they've got all the
newest and best documentary titles tons
of stuff i can't find on netflix or hulu
and curiosity stream is only 125 a month
when you use my link below if you're
looking for those new award-winning
documentaries they've got them if you're
looking for the classics from years ago
they have those as well i just watched a
fantastic documentary called deep time
history which goes into
early
like pre-history
fascinating and curiosity stream has an
app for all of your devices tv phone
computer whether you want to watch a
serene nature documentary on the couch
or check out a juicy political
corruption story curiosity stream has
you covered you can get curiosity stream
for 15 bucks a year that's a dollar 25 a
month only when you go to
curiositystream.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below